trevor wallace discusses his first
shroom trip i think i did that perfect
amount and we it was me and three other
people in palm springs and just like an
airbnb it was like fake middle of the
pandemic and we all took the same doses
at the same time and it all hit at once
for all of us it's really cool could you
talk or were you just like no no no it
was it was like a lot of like laughs a
lot of like giggles yeah yeah and uh i
remember eating a popsicle that was
pretty vivid pops
bright as hell
i thought i was at coachella or some
[ __ ] no we were all just like in a pool
and then like everything was so bright
staring at the water was really cool
i've only done mushrooms at night man
i've never done them in the day yeah
during the day i do crazy amounts though
and sit really like in my room by myself
damn because if you're in pitch black
what do you see your [ __ ] thoughts
it's like a projector and you're just
looking at whoa that's [ __ ] deep it
was very yeah but here's the thing i
have a lot of anxiety so i feel like i'd
lock that door and now just see like
godzilla with his [ __ ] come here trevor
[Music]